even when i come to the hospital and i
see you in your [ __ ] nerdy ass lab
coat and [ __ ] i always make sure people
understand that you're a great athlete
because i feel like i you know got you
there i beat your ass every day of your
life i made you a man i toughened you up
all american football all city dc
basketball played d1 sports uh well
anyways you were good in baseball which
also was frustrating as [ __ ]
[Music]
today is a very special guest one that
i've known for his entire life it's my
little brother nick bernthal nick was an
all-american athlete played division one
sports set up hospitals all over the
world has now become one of the most
revered cancer surgeons in the country
for as well as i love and respect and
know my little brother today i feel like
i got to know him a little bit better
look nick you got [ __ ] cameras on you
dude
that make you nervous
huh
you know and and having this
conversation there's always a
a need for me to explain and i have to
explain to everybody in the room
that uh that that nick my little brother
here is actually like an elite athlete
right and i i say that you don't look
like that you definitely definitely
don't look like it and the thing is is
is because i
i [ __ ] it's be and and i do take that
as my response i beat your ass every day
of your life i made you a man i
toughened you up but like what you uh
all-american football all-city dc
basketball played d1 sports and good at
like really all [ __ ] games it's
frustrating you play baseball what like
what like your junior and you were were
you all league in baseball
uh
don't act like you don't [ __ ] know
dude were you all league in baseball
well anyways you were good in baseball
which also was frustrating as [ __ ] like
even when i come to the hospital and i
see you in your [ __ ] nerdy ass lab
coat and [ __ ] i always make sure people
understand that you're a great athlete
because i feel like i
you know got you there and i guess you
know to start man i wanted to know like
from athletics like what is what is some
[ __ ] that you you you have taken from
from sports you know i think i think for
me sports kind of started out just being
something about um when you're the
youngest brother sports are a way that
you can
engage with your older brothers and and
for us as you know i mean growing up in
a house with with guys and sports all
around everywhere it was for me a way of
kind of being included that i felt like
if i could kind of
be good enough to play in that get that
that that was it like that's the goal
that's the goal is being good enough
that you're not kind of
the weakest link in a sport but
you know then from that i think you know
there's all the cliche [ __ ] the
relationships and the growing up in dc
and the kind of the the links it made
across but i think deeper
um
you know the deeper friendships when you
start talking about things that actually
put people on an equal playing field
i've always just really
kind of
i've loved the idea of sports it's one
of the few areas where everybody
puts on a uniform and
um
it doesn't matter who you are where
you're from what your parents look like
what you look like i mean none of this
stuff matters and so it always felt like
it was this place where it's a true
meritocracy you create your identity and
you earn your identity and nothing's
given to anybody
and and so um
for me that was a big part of it i mean
dc is a multi-racial city it's a
multi-background city and and um there
just aren't that many places
they equal opportunity it's just like
you you're judged by that's how hard you
work and how much you get you get each
other and growing up sort of like how we
did and where we did and when we did um
i
i i think was just so
like just unbelievably unique and i
think everybody has their own sort of
relationship with their upbringing i'm
constantly going back to how we grew up
and um i'm just like so
enormously grateful for it and um and
first i just want to talk about like
just like the environment of that and
and you know i was thinking about you
today and you know and like in the
course of your life like growing up as
like a high school student you know you
drive your little shitty ass car to the
[ __ ] white house you know what i mean
like your [ __ ] broken down car with
no air conditioner no radio and like
amazing and like pull up at the white
house and like watch football bill
clinton and then you also had you know
dear friends that you know who parents
were you know first-generation
immigrants you had friends whose parents
you know your best friend's dad was a
cop you know you you had friends whose
parents were incarcerated you know we
knew kids that
you know had had been incarcerated been
shot and killed you know there's there's
just such exposure i think in in in a
city like dc at the time we grew up
where you have this like unbelievable
power center but it's also just this um
city with his own you know super vibrant
culture and there it was a violent city
and a live city and an artistic city i'm
just wondering like how do you feel that
like how would you characterize the way
that we grew up in the environment we
grew up in and like how has it served
you
i think as far as like the the dynamic
of dc and and how it's i think one of
the really cool things um
is that there is a
sort of genuine uh
peace and comfort level in almost any
group that comes out of growing up that
way where you can really give people a
shot where you can really sit
and not worry about what you look like
to them or what they look like to you on
kind of first pass if you grow up an
environment like that i mean part of it
is that the valued resource in dc was
never wealth which gets passed down it
just never was really about wealth it
was never about fame
which in you know these famous families
in california these wealthy families in
new york yeah dc was never really about
that i mean things change so fast
there's elections this guy is the most
important guy this month and then the
next guy but but you know in dc as a
city um it really felt like um
the things that were valued were much
more uh
kind of what you had to say what your
thought process was um and it integrity
integrity i'm afraid you were yeah i
mean those things really seem to just um
be there you know obviously like you
know better than anyone else like nobody
needs to sit around listen to [ __ ] my
ass like pontificate about politics or
culture or any of that [ __ ] i you know i
i've just been
you know really just like disturbed and
and um disappointed at like the just the
the state of discourse right now in in
in the country and i think it's just
like we're listening to the wrong
[ __ ] people and it's like loudest
voice in the room wins and i think that
that's against like everything that i
believe in my heart my soul and how we
were raised and um i think we're so
[ __ ] divided right now that you know
strength and
sort of patriotism um it's just it's
just all about bravado it's all about
bluster it's like how how hard can i
[ __ ] cheer for my team over here how
stringently and stridently can i hang on
to my [ __ ] point of view and that's
mistaken with again with with strength
and masculinity and and um fierceness
and and um so i guess like what i'm
really trying to do is is expose people
and like bring in like interesting
people that i think embody wisdom and
and and strength and education and
discipline and integrity and and and
kindness and empathy and i think i i
wanna i wanna just like give examples of
that and like honestly man like
you know even though i do take a lot of
responsibility for you know all of your
success i you know i think you are a
perfect example of that and when i think
about people who i would want in my
corner i can't think of anybody more
than you and
but i also think about just like the way
that we were raised in our house and my
mom and dad and when you think about it
you know look our our parents eventually
were foster parents and literally
brought kids in our house raising
themselves but like for 40 years man
like
mom had a [ __ ] open door policy like
it didn't matter how [ __ ] up you were
how much trouble you were you could be
running from the police you had a hot
meal and a bed in our house like you
were you were you were part of our
family pops like always had an open door
like no matter what you [ __ ] did you
could go to him even without going to us
first like you could go to him and he
would [ __ ] help you out and like do
whatever he could to like make you okay
and and and you could bring anything to
him and we grew up i think with this
like tribe
of people i mean huge [ __ ] group of
kids and like you know really like a
competent you know powerful group of
people now from all [ __ ] walks of
life all races all religions all
socio-economic levels like i'm so
grateful for growing up that way and i'm
so grateful like like like that support
and that base that that that we have it
it's it's it is the reason you know that
i feel like i can like go out and and do
what i do and i'm sure you feel that way
too surgery we talk about things being
strong like palm trees rather than
strong like like oak trees was that like
an oak
and like a
you know an oak if you have a really
rigid tree
it it's looks really sturdy you hit on
it it doesn't go anywhere but in a storm
it falls
right in a storm it's rigid is brittle
and so it's very stuck and
and
you can't conceptually
kind of fix things you can't put bones
together when they're broken and make it
rigid they actually won't heal you
actually need to make them like a palm
tree so they have some give in the
system so that they can respond to
stress because it lets the body
actually heal and mend and grow stronger
so when you heal a broken bone
it the goal is to create a palm tree you
create something with a little give in
it and and i think you know to me that's
that that's the metaphor that is kind of
the building the solid foundation it's
got to be planted it's got to be rooted
but like the concern is does the kind of
current climate go so far that you have
the overprotective side of things in
growing up that you control everything
and you build it rigid on its way up and
it has no ability to tolerate a storm it
has no ability to to
sort of respond to stressors and so you
know i think that's the goal i mean all
of us is young parents trying to raise
kids like that that's the environment
you're trying to create and i think a
household that says the doors open
whatever you do i got your back but i'm
going to tell you when you make a a bad
decision i'm going to try and teach you
from it we're going to
bring in everybody from all walks of
life because you don't know what stress
or what's going to make you stronger
what's going to make you weaker and and
so i think that that
model certainly holds you know i think
obviously like right now we're like
sitting here in the middle of this
[ __ ] pandemic and um there was like
two things you know that i found like
really hit home for me i mean i think
number one like losing adam you know
like losing our cousin spent every
christmas with him uh
you know
unbelievably
you know probably the most talented
person you know i've ever it's like he
was the em emblem he like he meant
talent to me he was like first thing i
had first sort of an example like he he
could just you could throw it in front
of him and he could do it blow your
[ __ ] mind dude
and and music and and and like you know
man it's like you know this covet thing
hit and you know you were sort of you
know you were the one that like
everybody obviously was going to and
talking to him being like what's it like
anytime anybody has like
in the tentacles of our of our family
which is you know probably in the
thousands like people are hitting you up
and you're always there for them and
you know you were on the phones with the
doctors and you were you were you know
i'm like look man like you you had to
break the news to your aunt and uncle
that you know that there they'd never
see their their boy again and you know
you two young girls a young man perfect
health and you had to break that news
and i thought about you so much in that
and that like what that [ __ ] must
have been like to call
you know bobby and steve and like and
then like i realize you do that kind of
thing sort of all the time and just like
i know how much empathy you have and i
know how much heart you have you're not
like an aloof cold person it's like how
do you [ __ ] deal with that and i
guess you know what was it like to sort
of be faced because it was the first
time i sort of could go to you on
something and you were like dude i like
i don't know we don't know you don't
[ __ ] know and and what was it like to
sort of be faced with that and
and
have no frame of reference for it and
like how how common is that yeah
incredibly rare for us as a field i mean
it's the first time i can remember and i
think the guys who are a little bit
older than me talk about it with the hiv
epidemic at the very beginning in san
francisco that that that was the feeling
that you just didn't know what was
hitting you but you knew something bad
right um
but you know i i think the deal with the
beginning of covid that made it just
uniquely difficult to help
patients and people and friends through
this
is that um you know i live in the cancer
world
primarily and in cancer man something
bad goes on
and everybody coalesces it's amazing you
watch what families do
when somebody is suffering and somebody
is struggling with cancer and it
it
can
be the hardest thing in the world but
more often than not man it brings out
the best in everybody around and
infectious disease stuff in covid
it is the most isolating thing i mean
you go through an icu and you saw
especially at the beginning they were
letting nobody anywhere near these you
couldn't see your family you weren't you
couldn't say i mean that was bobby and
sit there adam adam said you know they
held a phone through two windows to say
goodbye to his daughter like his
daughter said goodbye to him through a
phone across two windows and
um
that was something none of us could come
to grips with and you start seeing
um
the isolation of it i mean and this was
it was adam's story but it was so many
people's story of like i think i'm okay
i'm a little feeling a little crappy
there's this new pandemic i'm gonna go
to the hospital to just get it checked
out right and then you're gone you never
see and you disappear and you never see
anybody again
that is a horrifying kind and you know
as a doctor of your level i mean we've
failed like america has like
failed compared to the rest of yeah i i
just don't there's no objective metric
you can use that doesn't say we've
failed miserably our our system is
really good at certain things
um
this has exposed some of our biggest
problems uh and
we didn't what we've always kind of held
on to is once we unleash our system at
something that we had so much upside
that we could always deal with it right
that's the way our health system works
is but this exposed just it's exposed it
exposed some really big flaws in that
system what does kovid reveal about the
american health system so for me if it
was about not having
any
central organization in our system makes
it very hard to identify best practices
and respond to them so from a system
standpoint it's you know you you go to
to the uk
and
you know the 90 of the patients are in
the nhs or in the national health system
and so you can see one hospital is doing
better than another immediately that's
recognized how does that best practice
get conveyed to everybody else in our
system everybody was kind of doing their
own thing and trying to communicate as
best we could but it's info it's emails
it's hey this is what we're doing does
that work for you and it's just because
you have a friend in seattle who
happened to do it that way you're doing
it this way in la
and and that's just not
that's not the way to handle it then
kind of after the initial
process then it just became a thing
about who can get resources i mean then
it became a resource grab and so
suddenly states are competing with
states hospitals are competing with
hospitals and like the reality is is
like there's a finite number of
everything right right you are like
definition
taking away from somewhere else and like
that that's our system right right you
know and so once this thing got into a
phase of past the first month
at that point the big rich hospitals
were able to get stuff the less
resourced hospitals were not
and everybody started fighting over the
same research that's why more poor
people and and people of color are dying
from this thing well so so i i there's a
combination i mean these are things are
all multi-factorial but you know for
sure
that
there is better
there is care that we can provide at our
hospital
because of the resources we have that
are not being provided at other
hospitals now whether people are dying
because of that
or in addition there are medical
problems i mean now we know obesity
leads to big prob there's obesity in
underserved communities is a huge
problem we're also like living in a
country right now where there's like so
much conspiracy theories and there's so
much like that just like ripe with just
like [ __ ] i mean like how do you
feel about conspiracy theories like are
they dangerous and like like
the whole thing is i mean now it's it's
spiraled into madness and it's gotten to
a point now where um
you know i i try and think about this if
you break it down to a microcosm
of
a patient walks in
who's got a cancer right
i'm about to go through this treatment
what i think is going to be the best
shot they've got
if we don't establish the ground rules
of they've got a cancer if they don't
buy that they've got a cancer if they
don't buy that the cancer will kill them
if we don't go down this road if we
don't buy the facts kind of going into
the system
my discussion about how to treat them is
totally a waste of time right right and
and they can't get there and so now
we're just unfortunately like culturally
we're in a phase of
of no underlining facts or trust to
start this thing
and and you know not to get overly
political with it but it's like it's
it's just we're in a an undermined
culture right now and with covid that's
what we missed is that nobody from the
beginning said here's where we are
here's what the under this is the facts
as we know them they are going to change
this is a disease we don't know that
much about but here's what we do know
and
you know the unwillingness to have the
hard conversation up front this desire
to like just make things into the facts
we want them to be yeah i think is one
of those things that like any cancer
patient will tell you that's just not
how the world works right like that's
that's not you get the set of facts you
get right and then you've got to make
decisions with them and if you can't
accept that starting point
is that how it worked in other countries
i mean that's how we're of course yeah i
mean that's that's other countries
countries that were successful countries
that were successful say this
conversation sucks i'm an elected
political leader i got to lock it down
yeah you're gonna businesses are gonna
close bad things are you're gonna
[ __ ] like me my [ __ ] haters and
you know what yeah i say this to every
patient walks into my office when they
come in with a new tumor that we haven't
biopsied i say look i i have to shoot
straight with you i look at thousands of
these images this looks like cancer this
is probably going to be something bad
i hope that the next 20 minutes when i
talk about what's gonna happen if this
is cancer i hope that two days from now
when we get the biopsy results back i'm
wrong and i hope that you're a little
pissed at me and you say look man why
did you put me through the last 48 hours
of worrying about this but like i'm a
grown-ass man i'm a teacher i'm an adult
you're an adult or a kid yeah and
amazingly the kids are even better at it
yeah but you say like i have to tell you
if i'm sitting here saying damn in my
head this is a cancer yeah and i'm
telling you well i hope this is just a
little infection that antibiotics will
take care of like
that undermines everything going forward
because then when i break the bad news
to you two days later right you're
sitting there saying was he holding back
he did keep looking at the screen and
when the fellow came in he kind of gave
him that worried look like do i have to
read into everything this guy said and
that's what we missed here yeah if you
don't start from having the conversation
that's just transparent yeah that says
these are the facts
as best as i can give them to you i'm
not perfect you're not perfect but this
is what we got as a starting working
place i would rather have you informed
and then saying damn that guy had me
worried about something he didn't need
to be yeah i went on that traveling
fellowship uh a few years back and and
that traveling fellowship started out
where
five surgeons would represent the united
states and canada and north america and
go to europe and travel around and teach
them what we're doing as best practices
and they would teach us best practices
and then the next year they would send
five surgeons back here and that's the
way information used to be passed that
all came from world war ii a bunch of
surgeons went over in world war ii
american surgeons went over and
volunteered to help the british
and they were like oh you guys are doing
things differently than us how can we
learn from each other so after the war
they were like we have to make this an
actual exchange
that was medicine in 1940s and 50s and
60s
now
you know that the day i come up with
something new i mean my lab works on
stuff all the time it it's two months
from when we discover it to when it's
published
it's out in the literature it's
searchable all over the world i get an
email a month you know a week after it's
published from someone in abu dhabi
saying i'm working on this hey what did
you guys do to get to this step you get
some so the idea of going it alone
is so absurd it's not going to happen
it's just totally totally the doctors
are all talking the scientists are
talking the doctors are talking the only
thing it can do
is create i mean the go it alone concept
it is a financial concept it's who's who
has ownership of this stuff where is the
intellectual property who's going to
benefit from that's not about driving
the science forward it science is past
that right right right i guess like
first of all like what may like i don't
even know if i've noticed but like what
made you want to be a doc i was kind of
doing my own thing you know i'm saying
yeah yeah
um
so i guess
you know
the big kind of transition point for me
was living in south africa so when i
went down there and i was kind of
working on um i was a politics major as
you know in college and i was working i
actually didn't know that i didn't give
a [ __ ] about what you're doing i'm sure
i'm sure yeah
but i mean you know i went down there
uh at a time that i i was
i kind of thought boy how much has
changed since then but i mean at a time
when you know i felt like
mom and dad always talked about the 60s
as being like the time when
history was being written in the united
states and that was the exciting time
and we kind of we grew up in the 80s and
90s and like
there wasn't
it was an amazing time to grow up
amazing place but i didn't feel like we
were writing america's history
and at that time i thought the most
interesting place in the world was south
africa like mandela had just you know
taken over was transitioning to taboo
and becky as the next president like
it's a it's um
apartheid it ended uh within the last
six years um big big changes and they
were writing their history
and so i went down there and i thought
you know i'm gonna get into politics i'm
gonna work on politics i this is where
the most interesting issue of our time
is and
you know i got down there and partly was
the timing of it like everything else in
life you know but i i got down there and
um the big pressing issue was health
policy and at that point hiv in south
africa more than a third of the
population had hiv
and um they were trying to figure out
what to do and it was one of those super
interesting times so i i spent my time
kind of
comparing and contrasting uganda to
south africa
and uganda was this country with a
military dictator
it had the worst hiv epidemic in the
world it wasn't like you sli you have to
rape your emergency
crazy crazy crazy stories about what you
need to do how you but they had a
dictator who in the early 90s
said this is going to wipe out our
country if we don't respond to it
and so he said i'm going to take i'm
taking action
he started putting up signs about safe
sex abstinence condoms whatever it took
he saw that it was going to ruin his
country so you have uganda this horrible
quote-unquote military dictatorship that
went from the highest rate in the world
of hiv
down to a very i mean single digits
in in a period when south africa this
new democracy the rainbow nation nelson
mandela getting all the world's
accolades their rate went up in the same
time up to more than a third of the
population and so i was down there
trying to figure out what we could learn
from uganda how we could apply it to the
south african experience how we could
and and i mean sadly because i mean you
know i'm pretty optimistic person like
what what i
um
what i figured out down there was that
uh there were political
obstacles that were not going to that
that my impact was never going to be
meaningful
at the end of the day and this is one of
those things that's just so sad to say
but like
you know the south african government
um
was so politicized at that time so so
you know it's five years after apartheid
tombow and becky is a new president
coming after a legend nelson mandela you
know mandela hands in power and he says
you know look i've gotten us through
apartheid
i've gotten it so
the economy didn't totally collapse i've
convinced people there's a future i've
aligned everybody but now the country's
yours you got to do the next steps
and then becky
uh got swallowed up man
he just unfortunately got in this
position
where he said
hiv despite how bad it is i i can't
solve it there's no cure there's no drug
what am i supposed to do so the only
thing i can do is basically push it
under the rug because we need political
successes we're a young black government
in africa that many people are trying to
prove we can't govern
many people are out there their biases
are to show what a failure we are
and so i can't take on an issue that
doesn't have a path to success and hiv
is a is an issue that i don't know the
path to success right and he recognized
that for better or for worse and it
turned out very much for worse and he
basically said the only thing i can do
is kind of sweep it under the rug sure
and what they did i mean they used the
first year i was down there they used
their entire hiv budget on making a play
a play a play like a theater play
that one of him becky's family members
was running was the producer of but they
made a play to like literally it was so
crazy they they started with condoms
and then they stapled the instructions
to all the condoms so all the condoms
had two holes in them oh [ __ ]
millions of condoms
so you had these things where it's an
issue they didn't want to address they
then had a couple of political missteps
at the beginning of it and then they
just said we gotta get away from this
thing like hiv just ain't it we can't
deal with it
and so
what happened for me is that i got there
and i was like that was almost it um
what happened what happened for me is i
was like you know i can work kind of
dedicate my health my my work and my
life to trying to help policy positions
for this government yeah but i don't
believe this government has the
political will to make changes they
don't want to touch this issue
and the doctors were out there fighting
it the doctors were going out so every
friday i got in the i got in this mobile
medical clinic from uct you know this
groud skir hospital these doctors would
get out there with no drugs no nothing
they'd get in a mobile medical clinic
they'd go out to the townships and you
know i'd spend my week being told never
go into that area right that area is a
no-go zone right then you drive in with
the doctors man people are coming in
hugging them they're trying to get with
the best they had they were like look we
can help their nutrition we can help
their general health we can treat their
tuberculosis which is flair
so um so the doctors were [ __ ] taking
the they were into it in the past they
were christians were just talking about
that [ __ ] not even i mean even worse
than not even i mean literally running
from it because they they viewed it as a
losing battle and that's kind of sim and
that's where we are yeah that's where we
are that's where we are holy [ __ ] i mean
i mean i i think i know the answer to
this but like why aren't you the lakers
team doctor like why aren't you like a
[ __ ] guy who does
sports injuries i mean i think i know
the answer obviously but like going into
oncology into cancer
um you know i mean that's uh i mean it's
certainly not for the money so like what
yeah so so i
i mean i think at the end of the day
like everybody else's path you sort of
you you tend to ping pong a little bit
and you kind of find your way and you
bounce off walls you know you kind of go
somewhere and then you find something
that's getting too far one way and then
you try and adjust
and so for me um you know that's
medicine was getting in through seeing
the doctors in south africa i was 100
committed
to being an infectious disease doctor i
mean that was the natural thing hiv that
was where my background in the policy
side was and then uh
and then i remember in medical school i
went in and met with the head of
infectious disease and and i said you
know i'm thinking about this as a career
can we talk about it
and he said to me um
look if you want to go raise your family
in a developing country and not have a
home base here in the united states
infectious disease is the way to go but
if you don't think about going down a
surgical path because if you want to go
in and have an impact on people
but not commit your entire life to
living somewhere away uh
that you can't do it with infectious
disease and so for me
um it goes back to the roots of our
family man like i just i i
more power to those who do it
but for me i wanted to have a home base
here i knew that i didn't want to raise
kids
bouncing country to country and dealing
with epidemic that just wasn't the life
that i wanted for the family side
so then i found the surgical stuff and
and got in with some uh orthopedic
surgeons who did
um international work where they'd go in
and and really make an impact and i saw
the impact they were making and i loved
the kind of sports mechanical part of it
um
the nice thing in orthopedics is that
patients really want to get better it's
one of these interesting things in
medicine that i think people who aren't
in medicine sometimes lose track of but
um you know it goes back to alignment
and there's no one more motivated than
orthopedic patients it's mechanical it's
all about like getting doing this
surgery rehabbing so i get my physical
life back and so patients are super
motivated we generally aren't taking
care of um the very old elderly trying
to prolong
end of life that's just not and so
you're aligned you're totally and so
that got me all uh got me kind of jazzed
for orthopedics i went into the field
and uh
then when i was in my training like i
got there and i did a sports medicine
rotation and then right after an
orthopedic oncology rotation and for me
it was a way to kind of ping pong back a
little bit
to i realized that that um
i don't have as much empathy as i
thought i did it's hard to have empathy
like i you know somebody telling me that
their rotator cuff hurt like in their
tennis serve wasn't as hard as it used
to need your help that i like i couldn't
fake it i mean i couldn't i couldn't
even get behind it to be like i you know
i and it's no knock-on yeah it just like
that didn't pull me into a kid with
cancer but you walk in and and i mean
you know how much uh dr eckhart's
like experience i mean my mentor you'd
walk into his clinic
every patient he took care of man
followed them for life
he saw them they'd come in for their
annual visits 20 30 years after their
surgery bring their kids and grandkids
and they'd introduce them and say this
is the guy that saved my life he took my
cancer out when i was 13. and like you
can't be in that office
and then be in kind of a a kind of a
non-life or death situation like that
and and feel for me it just was that was
it and and when you're in med school
because i lived with you i mean like we
me you and aaron when she was my
girlfriend we lived together in you and
i feel like i didn't really see you but
i really do i mean i remember like our
cat was always in like in heat but i
don't really
i mean i was just so [ __ ]
you know self-centered like i was like a
struggling broke failing [ __ ] actor
who could not get a break and i was
totally self-centered you know the
careers people choose and their training
and what they go through to get there
is all about
what
tolerance for what type of hardship
like what what what challenge
does your personality allow itself to
what are you willing to take on and so
you know if you want to be an actor
like you deal with a lot of uncertainty
and you're willing to take on the hard
work and then not knowing that if you do
a it will lead to b that's an
uncertainty that like that i can't deal
with that yeah i i went through my whole
life knowing if i do a i get b if i do b
i get c you know you get that grade you
get into that place you get in that
place you get that degree you
and so i never had a day
where i thought
man what if what if i do all this and it
doesn't work out right that's that's not
a skill set you need in medicine right
um there's a really big difference in my
mind and
about like what makes good and great
doctors
and and how you tease that apart and
this is something that um
you know i remember one of one of the
guys at my program where i trained used
to always say
never never let your patients see you
eating
never let your patients see you eating
why your patients do not want to see you
as a human being yeah they want to see
you as their doctor
like go eat somewhere else go hide in a
corner doesn't matter but your patients
don't want to know your troubles they
don't want to know your home life they
don't want to know and it was just this
thing he would put on
his
mask his cape whatever it is every day
when he got to work and he was like i am
supposed to be this
to be a doctor i think that you can be a
really good doctor that way i do think
it's hard to be a great doctor that way
i think i think you have a level of
um
engagement with your patients
that helps you get over uh
that that allows you to be connected to
them in a way that that
um really helps what you do
and um trying to find that line between
engagement and and enough disengagement
that you can stay sort of cognitively on
the right track and you can stay
objective-ish in your decision making
um but at the end of the day
if you can't take on
some of the emotional tie to being
connected to them
you can make a scientifically correct
decision that is not a medically correct
decision and to some degree i mean
everybody's got to draw their line where
they draw their line you know like i
i've kids who die
from their cancers and
um i can't let that no matter how much
it eats at me i can't let that not allow
me to go in and do the best job or to
change decision makes so i got to learn
from anything that's happened in my past
but i can't there are times that you do
everything right and cancer you can do
the best surgery in the world
and take out the cancer kids doing great
three months later the cancer shows up
in their lungs and that kid dies you sit
there and rethink all of the decisions
you made along the path was it worth it
to do that surgery did i put that kid
through more pain than he needed was he
gonna die without that surgery could i
have avoided that what and
but the next kid who walks in
you have an obligation to to
sit there and and try to go through it
with them and make the best decision and
not let
you know not say man my last kid died
after i did this surgery
that's just not a choice you have right
right so you divorce yourself from that
but
um
i don't know man i mean it goes back to
the bigger picture like i i just um i'm
much more optimistic about how strong
people are than i think a lot of our
global narrative is right now and
unfortunately we live in a world that
like
is all about
um trying to convince us that we're weak
and everybody everybody is
weak everybody needs stuff everybody
over there
everybody is yeah
and like the truth is is i spend my life
with people who are getting real tough
news yeah and um people are extremely
strong
and families are strong kids are strong
and resilient
and and when you
can frame that we are aligned in this
i'm going to give you everything i have
but we're aligned in this and i can't
promise you i'm not going to tell every
kid walks in and says first question am
i going to die from this and i have to
say i can't tell you no but i think
we're going to beat this okay
and if i tell them you are not going to
die from this we're broken you have to
yeah like we're we're
we're done i mean most of
what i do
is um is curative
so most of it i truly believe we're
gonna take this cancer out
and you are going to have a very good
chance of coming in that day to the
operating room with cancer and walking
out without it and having your life back
and so that for me i mean that's the
that's the fuel that's the that is what
you feel
um keeps you through it sounds like most
of the time what you are confronted with
in those situations is like unbelievable
strength and resilience and
it is
crazy you cannot it's just like saying
you can't watch the news and not be
depressed like you cannot deal with
pediatric cancers and not be inspired no
nobody is around those kids and doesn't
come out and say like
it it i mean dude
very recently um
i took care of a girl
who you know young teenage girl
who um
had
literally a 50 pound tumor in her arm
arm completely non-functional get no
nerve function at all the arm's just
dangling literally like uh like a lead
weight off of her
and the arm is
you know that big around
and she and her family had
um really bounced around to some of the
best places
in the country
trying to find somebody who would do a
limb salvage operation
and so limb salvage means we can take
the tumor out but keep the arm
and an amputation is the opposite so 95
of what i do is limb salvage surgery and
i think there's a lot of surgeons and a
lot of us like our predilection is to
see limb salvage is a success and an
amputation is a sort of a surgical
failure
and i talked to her about it and i said
look you know that this is you do not
have any tumor anywhere else in your
body like this you got to give this arm
up you really we got to get there
because if we do a limb salvage we're
going to leave tumor cells behind and
it's going to come back and take your
life and you're a teenager and i know
you don't want to give up your arm but
it's non-functional it's not doing
anything for you it's never going to
work again i can't make it work
and she
she said no i've heard this from other
surgeons and i said look just make a
deal with me like come let's let's meet
a couple of times let's talk through it
meet my colleague meet my partner dr
fetterman who's just amazing with kids
who does the medical oncology side
just let's go through the process and
try i promise you we will make a
decision you're comfortable with
after a couple of visits
she said to me um
she would she would go for it
she said i get it um
and her parents were pissed off at me he
said we came here because we heard you
were the guy who could do limb salvage
and you were the guy who you know and
they traveled here changed their
insurance did all this stuff
um people pick up their whole families
and uproot for this i mean if your kid
you can save your kid's arm man you'd
move anywhere yep
and um
you know i i was really having a hard
time because it looked like the parents
um saw this as a massive failure
and um she decided
reluctantly but she decided after these
conversations to go for it
um she woke up and i mean young teenager
dude think about what you and i were
doing as a teenager yeah you know she's
15 years old
she wakes up from the surgery with her
arm off
and i walk in to check on her and just
say you know how you holding up in the
recovery room she's 20 minutes out from
this
and
she says two things to me she says can i
give you a hug
so i lean in she gives me a hug with her
one arm
and then she says you know this must
have been really hard for you wow
and it's like dude
yeah you know you like
you don't go through that you walk out
of that room and like you tear up a
little bit on your own and you get away
from it and um
and then you come back and you just
realize that like
man people are strong yeah
people bounce back man and and
she's gonna go and kick ass you've hit
on this a little bit but like who who
are the strongest
when facing like horrible news like do
you find you know religious people
people with great families people with
great friendships people with love in
their life like who people who are
really deeply religious have an
advantage in these really tough
situations i mean that's not nothing
yeah and um
you know there are i mean one of the
most interesting things for me was
operating in ethiopia like you go down
to ethiopia and um
we pray with the patient before the
surgery starts like you hold the
patient's hand
they don't get general anesthesia so
they're awake during the operation so
they're like prepped and draped and
they're sitting there and you have a
drape and they hold the drape down and
the patient leans forward and holds your
hand and you do a prayer with them
before they start
and they're just good they are good with
that like it was amazing like our their
patients were just like
they had not on anesthesia they have
local so they have a block so they don't
feel
most of it is not amputation um but yeah
i mean you do whatever surgery you need
to and they're awake with a regional
anesthetic just a block
but prayer
is so like fortifying uh culturally
there
um and again it not to group ever but it
just was kind of eye-opening i also as
you know i
i operated quite a bit and spent time in
utah where it's a much more religious
state and you see how religion factors
into these things and there was
acceptance of bad outcomes and
death as god's will
um and so it was much less what happened
why
what went wrong
you know all those questions
um so i think religion is is certainly
helpful um
and then i think it it it goes back to
resiliency goes back to being a palm
tree you know to having in your life
seen some storms
and um
knowing that you've weathered them and
the people around you have weathered
them
um
you know i think people who have not
seen any hardship
have a really hard time with even mild
hardship and have a hard time sure kind
of seeing through it yep so you know one
of the big challenges we got into and
part of the reason we're in the opioid
crisis that you know that's sort of
gotten pushed away as a second tier
issue right now but one of the reasons
we got there
was because
the
bad players on the pharmaceutical side
created
intentionally a marketing effort of
expectation that you should not be in
pain after surgery right or in other
places like you you're going to be
terrible you're going to have pain like
if i'm taking a tumor out and you're
cancer-free and this thing hurts
afterwards yeah
there's a certain degree of that that
you should be okay with yeah and not be
numbed too yeah yeah yeah and i i you
know people don't need to be tortured
but but you know and so when you operate
in other places that i think aren't
don't live with the same expectation
going in of comfort comfort of
outcomes being guaranteed yeah you know
here
there's this creepy culture where
something went wrong if it doesn't work
out the way you do who's at fault right
right and that's a challenging i mean
fortunately cancer it's not a huge deal
because we are pretty aligned with our
patients but a lot of my colleagues like
you know that that plays big part in
what they do yeah medical legal words
who's consumed like who's
i'm sitting there trying to do the best
i can and you know and so
you go to other places and like people
um who don't have access
uh
life is not
expected necessarily to work out exactly
the way you want and any deviation from
that is not seen as a big problem right
like
life has a lot of uncertainty what do
you change about health care in this
country you know what what what is what
is your idea going forward about the
best advice that you can give
so so
this is where i i think i move a little
bit away from
the sort of my political views party
line on this um
so i look at
what america's role in health
as a global issue
so if you instead you say you know if
you just focus on our country probably
the best the right answer to this
is focusing on preventative health i
mean that's the right answer if you just
think like textbook
we got a lot of people with
problems that could be prevented with
more access to health care that's
definitely right there's no question
i think if you take a slightly wider
lens of it though
and so i try and think about health as
what's going to move humanity
forward a little bit and how healthy we
are
and i think there are countries
that can work on how best to improve
access better than us and then we can
learn from it and what we're really good
at is innovation it's what our country
is good at
and so whether it's for all the wrong
reasons whether it's capitalistic or
whether it's because we've got so many
incredible science i mean for decades
our universities were able to recruit
the best and brightest from all over the
world and just like so many other things
america was the place to come and do
science
and so i think at the top tier
we have the capacity to innovate and
part of that fragmented system that
delivers sometimes not great centralized
care
means that you have more people doing
different things and you can actually
innovate better in that respect
so i think it's really create a system
that
addresses access issues
but does not take away
the diversity at the top and the push to
be the global leader and i think a lot
of times we see those as competing we're
either going to focus attention toward
equality and equity in care
or we're going to devote resources to
exceptional care we're going to devote
resources to finding new cures
and if you say i've got one dollar and i
got to put it in either bucket then
you're right like you got to decide
which bucket but i don't think it really
is that way i think we can support
some degree of innovation and fragmented
i kind of understand what the [ __ ]
you're talking about but yeah all right
let me just [ __ ] like dumb it down a
little bit man yeah all right i mean for
[ __ ] sake dude so so
the the bottom line yeah is that if you
have a bunch of different hospitals
doing it different ways it is not going
to be an organized system so in britain
where they have the national health
system
like everybody walks in and they go and
the whole idea is get care to be
so that the lowest level of care is
pretty high right right right right
right but to do that just like in any
other thing in life
to some degree you're going to bring the
top performers down because you're going
to focus all the resources on bringing
the bottom up yep
and so what we the problem is is that
our system is so ill-suited for that and
we lose out on what
our country is really good at by doing
that i mean if we shift to a completely
nationalized system where everything is
about equality
what happens is innovation and tech and
sort of development go away they go
somewhere else where it allows the
differential because if i think i'm the
smartest guy in the world if i think
that i'm going to discover the next cure
for a big cancer
i cannot be in a system that makes me
behave exactly like the guy who just
clocks in and wants to get out two hours
later and it's just giving whatever the
protocol says this drive to that okay
and so you gotta be able to create a
system that says here's our baseline
we're obligated to treat basic health as
a right
but we are still going to
[Music]
kind of be the the magnet for the top we
are still going to be the people who who
push the envelope and how do you do that
so you're saying bring the bottom up
take it you got to take care of the
baseline establish establish what are
what is core
health care and that needs to come up
that needs to come up no matter what
because right now it's just that that
that disparity in health is just that
that is not acceptable i mean we are
worse in many ways our bottom are worse
off than many very very poor developing
countries and that just can't be it
can't be yeah um
but
it can't be and this is one of the
problems man like everything is so
polarized right now these are seen as
binary choices do you support the police
how do you do both or do you or do you
support racial equality right like why
can't you why can't you do both yeah why
can't we have a new forced approach
right to science that says
we want to invest in both innovation and
excellence
and reward that
but also enhance
the bottom end and that just takes
reorganization i mean that that just
takes investment reorganization
political will
and and and effort and a nuanced
non-blustered [ __ ] conversation just
like a a yeah for sure that something
that supports equality at the bottom is
going to hurt me at the top or something
that supports me at the top is going to
hurt the the the
you know the guy here it doesn't
you know
it just doesn't need to be that right a
capitalist culture is going to sell what
sells and so we don't do a particularly
good job of protecting our society
from things that are addiction forming
and addiction has this negative
connotation we're all addicted and we're
sitting here hugging our coffees like
everybody is addicted to stuff and
um there's no question
that we can do better um that we have
the science to show what is addictive
and what should be avoided unless you
want to accept risks of addiction i
think the one challenge is that
you know we have this other side of our
political spectrum that's about freedom
of choice yep and that's about the the
right to go get a candy bar if you want
a candy bar and and so culture has
gotten so toxic about any sort of
um intervention any sort of restriction
that takes away my freedoms
and so you know
at the end of the day you know in new
york they had the the soda taxes and you
know
you have to have
buy-in on these things culturally
rather than regulation as the driver my
tendency is um quite frankly to try and
that we can educate people a lot better
and not regulate people
that we can
i worry about
um
anything
that comes off as a
ban
of behavior because i think it in
practice
turns something into a political issue
which creates automatic friction
and i just think unfortunately we have
really crummy communicators
we have people who have not been able to
say look
you know yes a candy bar is going to be
available until a candy bar is not
profitable that's just unless we change
the little cookies oh you want your
[ __ ] vegan [ __ ] you want your vegan
you're a california yeah you're a this
you're the eater so let's put some
compelling people
in front and just say this is that and
say this is the deal you want your kid
to be
you know hooked on
diabetic causing sugars and all this so
like go it's available yep yeah like i
we're not going to regulate it but let's
like how do you compete i mean i guess
what you're asking too is like how do
you compete with the
the the the power of capitalism i mean
you see every kid in the world is just
stuck to their [ __ ] devices and [ __ ]
and like there are there are huge powers
at play pushing them towards those
things yeah but but i do think the one
place we are now man i think the one
there's so many scary things about all
of the information age and how
everything is going shooting around i do
think the compelling messages can be
heard like never before i think they're
celebrating people and places that do it
right listen i think you got to make fun
i mean for me it's like with my kids i'm
always like look at that [ __ ] nerd
like look at those nerds on their phones
like those people are sitting there with
each other on like have you ever seen
such that [ __ ] nerds playing video
games oh wait like and like i look i
don't want my kids to bully kids or
anything else but like they'd be like
dad that guy's a nerd right i'm like you
bet your [ __ ] ass like go climb that
mountain [ __ ] go wrestle each other
like you know what i mean we have to be
able to like point these things out and
and it not be like offensive
and and
and and look there's so much inequality
to it i mean it's like the the food that
is available
in places where people or you know
the haves versus the have nots a lot of
people are not informed in a meaningful
way about what their what they are
setting their families up for and i just
believe in the intelligence of people i
believe that people are like the coastal
elite [ __ ] where like we know it and but
the people in the middle of the country
just aren't smart enough to figure it
out like that shit's crazy yeah yeah but
it's like
but but that was the thing man that was
the thing that was the argument when the
hiv drugs came out with africa well i
was going to say that
it's the same [ __ ] it was like we all
said like oh we can't the drugs are too
complicated how could these uh
uneducated africans take drugs that are
scheduled every eight hours what if they
don't have a watch right we don't like
these are like [ __ ] insane arguments
right for why people shouldn't have
access to good information so what our
country has to do what the government
has to do
is figure out
some compelling ways to communicate
figure out some compelling people to
communicate and not polarizing and not
not marketing and not trying to get your
political agenda to look like there are
facts out there there is information out
there and so you know when we sit and
talk about
there are a lot of things that are up
for debate say they're up for debate say
we don't know how this impacts things
but if you talk about giving a bunch of
mcdonald's or candy bars to a kid every
day like we know what that leads to
that's a very clear line like let's be
transparent about it
and and you know it's just not that hard
yep one of the most common things i see
unfortunately
is that um
there's this whole group of cancer
survivors called aya and it's called
adolescent young adult
and these aya patients are kids who had
cancer and now they're late teenagers
and what happens is the health system
drops them
because as a kid with cancer there's
lots of resources in our health system
there's lots of social work there's lots
of support for the family everything
else
they get cured and and a bunch of them
go on to great things
but a bunch of them this is a really
traumatic experience going through as an
eight-year-old a year of chemotherapy
being pulled out of school being the
weird kid with no hair being the kid
with a limp being the kid
like and that [ __ ] does not catch up
necessarily in some kids it does but in
a lot of kids it doesn't so then they
become the teenagers
and they they hit the challenges of
adolescence
and and
something hits
and the thing that it combines in with
drug use as a kid because they've been
put on opioid i mean historically these
kids were given oxies that's what they
were given after every surgery after
every chemo you hurt oxyoxyoxac so many
of them have addiction biology in their
brain they go through natural hardship
and they're dropped the pediatric
sarcoma cancer people aren't with them
the adult people they're not really
plugged in because who i mean how many
doctors did you go see when you were 17
18 years old none right none of us like
that that's that's the time you're
healthy the way
people
uh deal with it and i think it goes back
to our our conversation at the beginning
of like you know
of trying and that's why it just sticks
in my head this like this palm tree idea
like you you've got to give yourself
sway you've got to give yourself room
for feeling it when when something
doesn't go the way you hoped the family
doesn't get the kid dies i mean that
[ __ ] happens
and if you don't give yourself sway you
will get blown down by a storm i i mean
i think the thing that that from my end
that's always been the the
hardest part to understand about your
world is uh
is
how you
um
how you deal with the
the notion or the concept
of how much fortune or luck plays into
something
and um
you know i've lived with you for a lot
of years over the course and i watched
you you know i i watched what it was and
i saw you know you the the work you put
in and the work you still put in every
day i mean for this like sit and
interview your brother you like you know
spent hours on on putting stuff together
and
um
you know but i but i do think you know
you talk about like
to some degree what we all care about
how we're perceived
and and um
you know i think that sort of
uh
that notion
that
acting
um or entertainment in general that
there's this just like you showed up at
the right place at the right time notion
that a lot of people outside this world
have and especially now frankly as
things have gotten polarized i think a
lot of it is like oh another hollywood
like think they have idea why do you get
to sit and do this show like you're just
a guy who happened to be
you know maybe a pretty fait i don't
know what the right but
um
but you know what i mean so listen man i
i look man i mean i i think number one i
think perspective is is is is everything
and there's no time no no question
you know again
you know like living in new york at an
extremely hard time for me with you
doing what you're doing and really like
aaron you know like
you know completely [ __ ]
self-made you know never got a [ __ ]
penny from anyone put herself through
college put herself through nursing
school became an icu trauma nurse like
worked in the the biggest trauma centers
in the world and you know i would face
rejection after rejection after
rejection going into these auditions
where people would literally be appalled
that somebody with ears like mine and a
nose like mine would walk in and
audition for this [ __ ] sitcom or this
wb show and like literally just like i
could feel they're disgusting me and i'm
like [ __ ] man i've studied all over like
i did my [ __ ] like i i've been in
theater companies i've been in hundreds
of plays where there was more of us on
stage than in the audience and i went
and studied in [ __ ] russia i got into
[ __ ] graduate school like with
nothing in like i studied and i worked i
worked and i worked and they want
nothing to [ __ ] do with me and the
hopelessness of it you know i there were
nights that you know i was like [ __ ] man
this ain't gonna happen and and i cried
myself to sleep and then like aaron
would walk in at like six in the morning
after working the night shift and
you know talk about you know holding a
guy's hand as he died or you know
holding a a young girlfriend of a guy
who i remember this guy got pushed down
in a fight and he hit his head and he
was gonna die and like aaron was like
with her and with the family and and the
perspective of that and the things that
you guys go through and and it would
always
just put the what the [ __ ] am i upset
about like put this [ __ ] in perspective
and i think you know perspective is
something i think also in our family i
often go back to our grandfather man
like you know like [ __ ] you know him
and his brother like 11 and 13 years old
like escaping [ __ ] nazi germany with
nothing with nothing you know running
out like sneaking in the storage
of a boat like getting to america not
knowing anyone like working in any job
they [ __ ] could with nothing like
just scraping by making money sending it
back having their parents come that
parents get turned around like [ __ ]
you know the nazis got him like you know
like you know when you think about like
perspective and and then and then you
think about like what is this life
[ __ ] about man and like for me like
you know man i was a [ __ ] you know and
like thank god you know
nobody gave up on me and and people
stuck by me because you know man like it
was like not looking good for a long
time and i could not
stay out of [ __ ] trouble and i could
not
you know like every bad path i was going
down but i i found this thing
that i [ __ ] loved and that i i i
connected me with something bigger and i
felt that i was put on this earth to do
and i was like the one thing you know i
i remember talking to pop about he's
like just [ __ ] work your ass off on
it just and like so for me it was like
look man if you have that that is
something nobody can take away from me
like i don't need to get hired in a tv
show i don't need to get hired on a
[ __ ] film like i have my passion i
have my art and like isla and i am in
control of how hard i go after it to
everything i do and and look i i think
as far as like this thing here it's like
i don't know what the [ __ ] we're doing i
just know that like i'm sick of
listening to [ __ ] celebrities man i'm
sick of listening to [ __ ] experts on
tv and pundits i'm sick of listening to
people who haven't been through [ __ ]
talk about things because they're
experts on it and like so i i really
and i understand that it is like
antithetical to my success to come out
like no one's gonna believe me as the
[ __ ] punisher no one's gonna believe
me as [ __ ] lee iacocca if i'm here
[ __ ] telling you about the way with
like our like my mystery and keeping
keeping like some removal between me and
my audience that is my [ __ ] currency
so like i'm super conflicted i
put clothes on my kids back and food on
the table by this acting [ __ ] that's my
love that's my passion it's my religion
and i know this goes against it and the
last thing i want to do is be another
[ __ ] celebrity spouting off that
being said you know i think family and a
sense of purpose i remember like
you know thinking about like you said
about the 60s and like looking back and
and and
the people who stood on the sidelines
and didn't do [ __ ] [ __ ] about it and
like what was that like like i get
there's like some self-interest there
but like you know man we grew up with
like pioneers of of a [ __ ] the civil
rights movement and people like not
[ __ ] who like dropped out and
[ __ ] did acid and like we're like
peace they were like [ __ ] who
like you know we were taught by people
we grew up with people all of our
friends parents our parents people who
like
got arrested protested went down to
[ __ ] the south you know when it was
dangerous when people were getting hung
and like stood up for what they [ __ ]
believed in so look man i don't know
what the [ __ ] this is but i think that
just like bringing in people who
you know walk the walk instead of talk
that [ __ ] and like saying hey look this
is like a strong fierce educated kind
empathetic person like we can be that
way and we can like talk to talk about
things and we could talk to people who
think differently than us you know might
just change a little bit of discourse so
i don't i mean that's that's my [ __ ]
up answer but i mean yeah man i and and
and i think i think like you it all goes
back to the family and the base and like
what we
what we had and and that you know the
certainty or uncertainty of what i do
it's all
it's all perspective just how you chan
you say you change your mindset
in terms of like you you remain hopeful
you remain optimistic you're telling
somebody hey you're not gonna make it
your child is not gonna make it but we
can do x y and z i think for me
i look at every job and i'm like this
might be my last job i've gone through
times where like i don't know if i'm
ever gonna work again right but you also
can look at that and you can say woe is
me and oh this is so hard or you can be
like man somewhere [ __ ] out there
that job is out there that thing that's
gonna like make me explore find parts of
myself i'm gonna get better it's out
there man and it might it could be
coming any [ __ ] second you just
reverse the way you you you you look at
it i think yeah i mean but i i mean
i think in the end though it is
um
it it goes back to
kind of
having some aspirational component to it
though i mean that's what you're it's
like there is something about moving the
needle changing the discourse having you
like
you sound like um
you know
looking at
life like we can do something of value
here and like keeping that
positivity toward your existence for
sure just seems like what what what's
lost right now agree and like what what
we are
so fixated on these um
on these differences on these you know
tribalism on this what what winning
losing words and saying this is what i
have more in common with this guy than
that guy and
um
i don't know i just how we got here is
amazing it's just amazing it's like i
definitely thought with obama like i
thought there was this moment of like
aspirational
unification that we were just like [ __ ]
man i don't know if it's gonna get
better but it sure looks like we might
work at it but i i but look i think the
only thing to [ __ ] do now is is to
stay aspirational is to stay like it's
like in in you know when times get tough
you know the tough better get [ __ ]
going i don't know what that's [ __ ]
saying but like you know i mean like
you've got to keep that going and we got
to raise our kids that way and we got to
raise them to be strong and to stand up
for injustice and to and and and to not
not play into tribalism on either
[ __ ] side
there's this [ __ ] chunk of people in
the middle
in the middle here that are not all the
way over here waving their flag they're
not over and this this is the group of
people that i think yeah he knows no
voice right they got no [ __ ] voice we
gotta give them a voice man
that's it gotta talk to him and gotta
not judge him gotta not be afraid you
know what i mean and and i think that
that's i think you know that's what the
[ __ ] you know
oh it's cool yeah man it's cool i really
appreciate you doing this man i'm very
proud of you dude thanks for thanks for
doing it i'm proud of you yeah dude i
love you man love you too buddy yeah man
i can still beat your [ __ ] ass though
all right let's go
[Music]
thanks for being here everybody i really
appreciate it if you dug what you saw
and you want to hear more subscribe like
do all that stuff and mean a lot to us i
hope you dig these episodes as much as
we dig doing them you guys take care of
yourself